thank you very much Paul it's my great
honor to be the person who reads the
citations and along with sig Gissler
hands out the awards and you know there
are certain days in the academic year
that really mean an enormous amount and
last week we had commencement graduation
ceremonies here and 40,000 people packed
into that space right out there which is
one of the truly great academic spaces
on the planet we have an honorary degree
dinner it's you know really says what
the institution is all about we have
convocation for students who come here
new and fresh and wanting to learn and
that happens in early September but the
Pulitzer Prize event this event stands
right up there with those great great
ceremonies that really bespeak the
values of this place and of the
profession and of the arts that all of
you have so successfully achieved in so
it's a great great privilege for me to
to do this and Paul is right i mean it's
an incredible discussion that takes
place about the works it's an
opportunity for everybody to speak
people say how they felt about the work
and there's listening i mean one of the
few times that people actually listen to
each other and then change their minds
and it's a it's a great great group to
be part of and of course the jurors are
unbelievable I mean the fact that they
read all of this so carefully and write
up really illuminating and occasionally
brilliant summaries of the work is is a
great tribute to the process so let me
begin sig so we start with public
service for a distinguished example of
meritorious public service by a
newspaper or new site through the use of
its journalistic resources including the
use of stories editorials cartoons
photographs graphics videos databases
multimedia or inner
active presentations or other visual
material the award goes to the sun
sentinel fort lauderdale florida for its
well-documented investigation of
off-duty police officers who recklessly
speed and endanger the lives of citizens
leading in this case the disciplinary
action and other steps to curtail a
deadly hazard congratulations please
come forward
accepting this is Sally keston and John
mains congratulations so we got
as you can tell i'm reading the the
language about the prizes and even
though it may get somewhat repetitive
and even though they're really elongated
sentences the fact that the board
debates these over and over and over
again makes them very meaningful so pay
close attention please for a
distinguished example of local reporting
of breaking news that as quickly as
possible captures events accurately as
they occur and as time passes
illuminates provides context and expands
upon the initial coverage the Denver
Post staff for its comprehensive
coverage of the mass shooting at a movie
theater in aurora colorado that killed
12 and injured 58 using journalistic
tools from twitter and facebook to video
and written reports both to capture a
breaking story and to provide context
Kevin Dale Tim Rasmussen Leanne
Colicchio RJ sangosti and Curtis Lee
will accept the awards please come
investigative reporting for a
distinguished example of investigative
reporting using any available
journalistic tool David Barstow and
Alexandra zanuck von Burt robbed of the
New York Times for their reports on how
Walmart used widespread bribery to
dominate the market in Mexico resulting
in changes in company practices
congratulations
explanatory reporting or a distinguished
example of explanatory reporting that
illuminates a significant and complex
subject demonstrating mastery of the
subject lucid writing and clear
presentation using any available
journalistic tool the New York Times
staff for its penetrating look into the
business practices by Apple and other
technology companies that illustrates
the darker side of a changing global
economy for workers and consumers Keith
Bradshaw Charles Duhigg and David
Barboza of the paper will accept the
award
Pulitzer Prize for a local reporting for
a distinguished example of reporting on
significant issues of local concern
demonstrating originality and community
expertise using any journalistic tool
Brad schrade and Jeremy Olson and Glenn
Howitt of the Star Tribune Minneapolis
for their powerful reports on the spike
in infant deaths at poorly regulated day
care homes resulting in legislative
action to strengthen rules
congratulations to the starch
they'll have to circle
Pulitzer Prize for national reporting
for a distinguished example of reporting
on national affairs using any available
journalistic tool Lisa song Elizabeth
McGowan and david has mire of inside
climate News Brooklyn New York for their
rigorous reports on flawed regulation of
the nation's oil pipelines focusing on
potential ecological dangers posed by
diluted bitumen or dilbit a
controversial form of oil
congratulations to you
international reporting for a
distinguished example of reporting on
international affairs using any
available journalistic tool David
Barboza of the New York Times or his
striking exposure of corruption at high
levels of the Chinese government
including billions in secret wealth
owned by relatives of the Prime Minister
well-documented work published in the
face of heavy pressures from the Chinese
officials congratulations David David
Barboza the New York Times
feature writing for a distinguished
example of feature writing giving prime
consideration to quality of writing
originality and concision using any
available journalistic tool John branch
of the New York Times for his evocative
narrative about skiers killed in an
avalanche and the science that explains
explains such disasters a project
enhanced by its deft integration of
multimedia elements congratulations John
branch from New York Times
next award is for distinguished
commentary again using any available
journalistic tool Brad Stevens of the
wall street journal for his incisive
columns on American foreign policy and
domestic politics often enlivened by a
contrarian twist congratulations Bret
Stevens
graduation
next award is for distinguished
criticism using any available
journalistic tool Phillip Kennecott of
the Washington Post for his eloquent and
passionate essays on art and the social
forces that underlie it a critic who
always strives to make his topics and
targets relevant to readers
congratulations Phillip Kennecott of the
Washington Post
next prize is for distinguished
editorial-writing the test of excellence
being clearness of style moral purpose
sound reasoning and power to influence
public opinion in what the writer
conceives to be the right direction
using any available journalistic tool
Tim nickens and Daniel Ruth of the Tampa
Bay Times saying Petersburg Florida for
their diligent campaign that helped
reverse a decision to end fluoridation
of the water supply for the 700,000
residents of the newspapers home county
please welcome congratulate calm Nick
and Daniel root
editorial cartooning for a distinguished
cartoon or portfolio of cartoons
characterized by originality editorial
effectiveness quality of drawing and
pictorial effect published as a still
drawing animation or both Steve sack of
the tower Star Tribune Minneapolis for
his diverse collection of cartoons using
an original style and clever ideas to
drive home an unmistakable point of view
congratulations Steve sack with the
starch of you
with this group breaking news
photography for a distinguished example
of breaking news photography in black
and white or color which may consist of
a photograph or photographs rodrigo
abdul manu brabo narciso Contreras
Khalil Hamra Muhammed Muheisen of the
associated press for their compelling
coverage of the civil war in Syria
producing memorable images under extreme
hazard congratulations
feature photography for a distinguished
example of feature photography in black
and white or color which may consist of
a photograph for photographs Xavier
Manzano a freelance photographer for his
extraordinary picture distributed by
Agence france-presse of two Syrian rebel
soldiers tensely guarding their position
as beams of light streamed through
bullet holes in a nearby metal wall
congratulations to both of you
and now we go to letters the Pulitzer
Prize in fiction for a distinguished
fiction by an American author preferably
dealing with American life the orphan
master's son by Adam Johnson an
exquisitely crafted novel that carries
the reader on an adventuresome journey
into the depths of totalitarian North
Korea and into the most intimate spaces
of the human heart congratulations Adam
Johnson
you
the Pulitzer Prize in drama for a
distinguished play by an American author
preferably original in its source and
dealing with American life disgraced by
Ayad Akhtar an moving play that depicts
a successful corporate lawyer painfully
forced to consider why he has forced so
long camouflaged his Pakistani Muslim
heritage congratulations I had Akhtar
history for a distinguished an
appropriately documented book on the
history of the United States embers of
war the fall of an empire and the making
of America's Vietnam by Frederick log of
all a balanced deeply researched history
of how as French colonial rule faltered
a succession of American leaders moves
step by step down a road toward
full-blown war congratulations Frederick
log of all
biography for a distinguished
inappropriately documented biography or
autobiography by an American author the
black count glory Revolution betrayal
and the real Count of Monte Cristo by
Tom reise reise a compelling story of a
forgotten swashbuckling hero of mixed
race whose bold exploits were captured
by his son Alexander Duma in famous 19th
century novels congratulations tom rice
poetry for a distinguished volume of
original verse by an American author
stags leap by Sharon olds a book of
unflinching poems on the author's
divorce that examined love sorrow and
the limits of self-knowledge
congratulations Sharon olds
the Pulitzer Prize in nonfiction for a
distinguished and appropriately
documented book of nonfiction by an
American author that is not eligible for
consideration in any other category
devil in the grove Thurgood Marshall the
groveland boys and the dawn of a new
America by Gilbert King a richly
detailed chronicle of racial injustice
in the Florida town of groveland Revelin
in 1949 involving four black men falsely
accused of rape and drawing a civil
rights crusader and eventual Supreme
Court justice into the legal battle
congratulations Gilbert King
graduate
we have to
oh I see
the Pulitzer Prize in music the last
award for distinguished musical
composition by an American that has had
its first performance a recording in the
United States during the year Caroline
Shaw for partita 48 voices recording
released on October thirtieth 2012
highly polished and inventa and
inventive a cappella work uniquely
embracing speech whispers sighs murmurs
wordless melodies and novel vocal
effects congratulations Caroline shot
ok
Thank You mr. president ladies and
gentlemen thank all of you for attending
our awards celebration all the work of
the winners can be found on our website
Pulitzer dot org and the next few days
we'll also be posting a gallery of
pictures and we'll have a video of the
event on our website as well my final
duty is to ask the winners to please
assemble on the steps outside the
building for your class photo once again
thank you very much and have a great day
David